[موسيقى]
احييكم واهلا بكم الى العربيه 360 كالعاده
نبدا بابرز العناوين
تصنف الصين وروسيا كمصدر تهديدا عالمي
تحذرها من استقبال رئيس التايوان تحت اي
ظرف وباي مسمن
بعد تقارير عن اياد اوكرانيه وراء تفجير
نورد ستريم اوروبا تدعو للتريس وموسكوت
تتحدث عن مؤامره للتمويه
تعتبر تصعيد ايران النووي تهديدا للعالم
وترفض روايتها عن نسب التخصيب
لدينا ايضا في 360
المراه في يومها العالمي محاربه في روسيا
مهدوره الحقوق في كابول وملاحقه في طهران
والشارع يتسع للشاكيات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اصدرت وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه تقريرها السنوي الخاص بتقييم
المخاطر في العالم والذي اشارت فيه الى ما
وصفته بالسنوات القادمه الحرجه بسبب روسيا
والصين وانهما ستواصلان تهديد العالم وقال
التقرير ان روسيا ستظل تمثل تهديدا كبيرا
للدول الاخرى وستستمر بمحاولاتها للتاثير
على الانتخابات الامريكيه وفيما يتعلق
بالصين اشار تقييم الاستخبارات الى ان
بكين ستطور من قدراتها لمواجهه الولايات
المتحده وبشان ايران وتهديداتها تحدث
التقرير عن مواصله طهران تهديد مصالح
واشنطن وانها ستكون مصدرا للاضطرابات من
خلال ميليشياتها كما اشار تقرير
الاستخبارات الامريكيه الى ان ايران لم
تاخذ خطوات واضحه لبناء القنبله النوويه
من واشنطن تنضم الى مراسله العربيه ريتا
سليمان اهلا بك معنا ماذا لدينا من او ما
هي حيثيات هذا التقرير ماذا لدينا من
تفاصيل حوله
هذا التقرير السنوي لاداره الاستخبارات
الوطنيه لتقييم التهديدات التي تواجه
الامن القوميه الامريكي ضمن جلسه الاستماع
السنويه في لجنه الاستخبارات في مجلس
الشيوخ يتم تقييم التهديدات التي تواجه
الامن القوميه الامريكي كل عام في هذا
التقرير حدد تم تحديد الصين كخطر اول
للامن القومي الامريكي وخلص التقرير انه
الصين ستستمر في مواجهه الولايات المتحده
خاصه ستزيد من تعاونها مع روسيا عسكريا
وتقنيا ايضا في الحرب في اوكرانيا فقط
لمواجهه النفوذ الامريكي خلص التقرير ايضا
بانه روسيا هي تهديد للامن القومي
الامريكي ايضا
ذكرت تقريبا بانه قد لا تريد روسيا مواجهه
مباشره مع الولايات المتحده او حتى مع
النيتو ولكن الخسائر الكبيره التي تتكبدها
في اوكرانيا تؤدي الى تضاؤل مكانه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وبالتالي ما يزيد
من احتماليه التصعيد في
الفترات المقبله وايضا اعود الى الصين خلص
التقرير بانه الصين مع زياده تعاونها مع
روسيا ستظل التهديد الاول للولايات
المتحده ولكنها ايضا ستستمر في زياده
ايراداتها العسكريه واصولها الاخرى
ومواجهه وتستمر في مواجهات عديده في بحر
الصين الجنوبي وخاصه في تايوان ستزيد من
عبورها لصديق في تايوان وستزيد من من ايضا
ارسال صواريخها فوق تايوان تحت بارث بهذا
الاطار بموضوع الصين ما هي ابرز التخوفات
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده بالنسبه لموضوع
زياده قدرات الصين وتحضير نفسها لاي
مواجهه كما ذكر التقرير هل الولايات
المتحده ايضا لديها اجراءات معينه
تتخذها بحال قامت الصين بهذا الاعتداء على
تايوان
التقرير ميسون يجب ان اشير بانه لم يذكر
اي تدابير ستتخذها الولايات المتحده بحال
تم هذا التقييم اي من هذه التقييمات التي
ذكرها التقرير ولكن دعيني اقول لك الجو
العام في واشنطن يبحث هذه الاجراءات وهذه
الاستعدادات ان كان عسكريا ان كان تقنيا
ان كان اقتصاديا وحتى في المجال
التكنولوجي وتيك توك اكبر دليل على ذلك في
اي مواجهه مقبله مع الصين ان كان الاداره
الامريكيه على استعداد وفي
مشاورات مستمره لوضع اي خطط في هذا المجال
وايضا على صعيد المشرعين في الكونغرس ان
كان مجلس النواب او حتى مجلس الشيوخ
يبحثون كل يوم هذه التداعيات وخاصه
تداعيات التقنيه
وهناك ايضا مطالب بتخفيف الاعتماد على
التقنيات الاجنبيه وزياده الاستثمار في
التق نيات الامريكيه هذا على صعيد
التقنيات ام عسكريا فطبعا البنتاغون في
بحث مستمر لوضع الخطط لاي مواجهه مقبله مع
الصين اشكرك ريتا على كل هذه المعلومات
على كل هذه التفاصيل كنت معنا من واشنطن
لتسليمان مراسله العربيه
ضمن حلقات التوتر بين واشنطن قالت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه ان بلادها
تعارض بحزم اي شكل من اشكال التبادلات
الرسميه بين واشنطن وترفض بشده زياره من
وصفتها برئيسه القوى الانفصاليه الاستقلال
تايوان الى واشنطن تحت اي مسمن ولاي سبب
[موسيقى]
الصين قلقه للغايه بشان المعلومات عن
العبور المزمعي لزعيم تايوان
والاجتماع مع رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن
مكاردي في الولايات المتحده لقد قدمنا
شكاوى رسميه الى الولايات المتحده
وحثثناها على تقديم توضيحات تعارض الصين
بحزم اي شكل من اشكال التبادلات الرسميه
بين الولايات المتحده وتايوان وترفض بشده
زياره رئيس القوه الانفصاليه لاستقلال
تايوان للولايات المتحده باي اسم ولاي سبب
نعارض بحزم اي اتصال بين الولايات المتحده
والقوه الانفصاليه لاستقلال تايوان كونه
ينتهك مبدا الصين الواحده قبل ذلك دع
الرئيس الصيني لدى لقائه وفدا يشمل قاده
عسكريين في الجيش الى تعزيز مرونه السلسله
الصناعيه وسلسله التوريد وتحسين قدره
الصين على معالجه المخاطر الاستراتيجيه
كما شدد على ضروره توحيد وتحسين النظام
الاستراتيجي الوطني
سيد نادر اهلا بكم معنا ساسالك عن التقرير
الذي تبعناه سويا في بدايه حلقتنا وفي
بدايه نشرتنا موضوع واشنطن تقول بانه اكبر
تهديد ما زالت الصين تشكله على العالم
ووضعتها بالتوازي مع روسيا هل من اصداء
لهذا التقرير داخل الصين
اهلا ومرحبا بكم اولا ترى الصين عن هذه
يعني التفاهم الخاطئ الصين ستجد ستؤدي الى
السرعه ومن بين الصين والولايه المتحده
يعني يجب على الولايات المتحده يعني
التعامل مع الصين بشكل عقلاني ويعني واقعي
للتعاون مع الصين للحفاظ على العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه لاعادتها الى مسار
التطور سليم وهذا
يساهم في
الحفاظ على السلام العالميه ككل
ولكن هل علقت على هذا التقرير بانها يعني
تشكل تهديدا للعالم ام لم تعلق ليس هناك
من اي تصريحات رسميه ردا على هذا التقرير
حسب الانمي حتى الان ليس هناك يعني
الردود رسميه تجاه هذه المده بالذات ولكن
هناك مواقف الصين اتجاه هذه المساله دائما
وهو ان تدعو ولايه المتحده يعني التخلي عن
يعني فكره الحرب البارده واللعبه الصفريه
لزياده
يعني زياده جهودها للتعاون مع السيد من
اجل مواجهه التحديات العالميه وعدم الحدوث
اي مواجهه مع الصين طيب هناك تهديد من قبل
الصين وتحذير من زياره رئيس التايوان الى
الولايات المتحده ما هو رد الفعل الصيني
المتوقع بحال حصلت هذه الزياره
طبعا هناك معرض شديده
وتعون يعني نراجع التاريخ في التسعينات في
القرن الماضيه يعني هناك اكبر ازمه بين
الجانب الماضي بسبب مثل هذه الزيارات
وهناك في تلك المره هناك التجارب الاطلاق
الصواريخ من بره رئيسي تجاهها
وقد يؤدي الى المواجهه مباشر بسبب هذا
واعتقد ان هذه المره اذا حصل سيكون هناك
تردد في الصيني اقوى من ذلك
ويعني قد يعني يدمر العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه بشكل كامل فهناك تحضيرات
الصينيه
متكرره لهذا لعواقب هذه مثل هذه التبادلات
الرسميه وكذلك هناك
من الخطوات الولايات المتحده بالدعم
واستقلال لذلك نتمنى ان لن نحضر
يحدث ذلك
سيدنا نادر اسمح لي ان تبقى معي سنذهب
لنتحدث عن احتمالات هذه المواجهه بين
الصين وتايوان طبعا الحديث عن هذه
المواجهه لا ينتهي احدث حلقاته الاتهام
للصين باجراء ما وصف بانه بروفا للغزوه
المحتمل لاعاده تايوان للسيطره
ولعقود طويله مضاده سنتحدث هنا مشاهدينا
عن فتره ما قبل الانترنت وهي التي يعيشها
حاليا ارخبيل تايواني نائم بالقرب من
السواحل الصينيه هنا مثلا في جزيره دون
كينج الصغيره التابعه لتايوان يعيش
المواطنين نموذجا لما يمكن ان يحدث
الحال وقوعي هجوم صيني انقطع الانترنت
فانعزل الارخبيل عن العالم والاتهامات
دائما موجهه لسفينه شحن صينيه قطعت كابلات
اتصالات تحت البحر تربط بالجزيره
التايوانيه الام ويمتد اربعه عشر كابلا
بحريا من تايوان بعضها مدفون على بعد
حوالي سته اقدام تحت قاع البحر لتوفير
خدمات الانترنت والاتصالات للجزيره
النائيه حرب اوكرانيا مثلا سبق ان اظهرت
مدى اهميه الانترنت لدوله تواجه هجوما
فاذا قطعت الصين اتصالات تايوان في حاله
الحرب سيكون التعتيم على ما يجري هناك
اسهل على حتى الان ليس لدى تايوان القدره
بمفردها على اصلاح الكابلات المعطله تحت
سطح البحر وتعتمد بدلا من ذلك على
متعاقدين من القطاع الخاص ليستغرق اصلاح
الضرر عده اسابيع تايوان اقرت بانها تبحث
عن حلول وقالت وزاره الشؤون الرقميه هناك
انها اجرت ابحاثا حول استخدام الانترنت
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه في حالات الطوارئ
مثل مثلا خدمه ستار لينك التي تقدمها شركه
سبيس اكس وتخطط الوزاره لتجربتها في اكثر
من 700 موقع طبعا
ساتابع هذا الحديث معك استاذه نادر لنتحدث
اذا كنتم لديكم اي معلومات او هل هناك من
اي تصريحات عن دور بكين مثلا في قطع هذه
الكابلات تحت البحر
ما هو رد الصين على هذا الاتهام
اهلا ومرحبا بكم حاليا يعني لا توجد
المصادر الرسميه تجاه هذه المساله ولكن
الموقف الرئيسي تجاه التايوان هو واضح
ومستمر
حتى في التقارير
العامل الحكومي
فهنا فهناك تشجيع
[موسيقى]
للتزياده التبادل وتعاون بين جانب المضيق
وكذلك تحسين اليات
يعني زياده رفحيه للشعبين
المواطنين
بين الجانب المضيق فلذلك
اعتقد هناك اولا هناك رفض من السلطه
تايوان لتبادل معبر روسيني الرئيسي وكذلك
رفض اعترافهم بمبدا السنه الواحد وهناك
الحصار هناك يعني كذلك تم
يعني انقطع الجميع والتبادل التبادلات
الثقافيه يعني بشكل كبير بعد الوصول الحزب
التقدم الديمقراطي الى السلطه عام 2016
ولذلك اعتقد يعني كان حتى هناك حذر
من السلطه في تايلاند
جميع الصادرات او بعد الصادرات من
البروسيا الرئيسيه فاعتقد هذا السبب هو
سبب رئيسي
لعدم
التواصل او عدم الحصول على احد الجزيره
على الامدادات او نقول
هذه المحاصره
يعني بشكل عام كما قلت
المستقبل الجزيره تايلان تكمل في الاعاده
التوحيد
الكامل للبلاد شكرا لك
على المشاركه معنا في العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 سنتابع بعد لحظات دفع اممي
اوكرانيين نحو تمديد اتفاقيه الحبوب
وروسيا ترفض التجاوب قبل تحقيق شروطها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد شكواه المتكرره من
نقص الذخيره على الخطوط الاماميه في معركه
باخموت وانتقاده لقياده الجيش الروسي في
هذا الشان
ظهر مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه اثناء حديث
مع احد المقاتلين في الخطوط الاماميه وهو
يتحدث عن هذه الازمه
اكدت عبر الهينز مديره المخابرات الوطنيه
الامريكيه ان روسيا بحاجه الى تعبئه
اجباريه ومصدر يمدها بالذخائر لتوصل
هجومها على اوكرانيا بنفس القوه
لو لم تبدا روسيا تعبئه اجباريه وان لم
تحصل على امدادات عسكريه من طرف ثالث
سيكون من الصعب عليها الاستمرار في الهجوم
بنفس القوه الحاليه خلال الاشهر المقبله
وقد تحول هدفها الى تعزيز السيطره على
مواقعها الحاليه لا نرى ان الجيش الروسي
سيتعافى هذا العام ليحقق مكاسب كبيره ولكن
بوتين يعتقد ان الوقت في صالحه وان
المواطنه في الحرب بما في ذلك وقف القتال
احيانا افضل طريق لتحقيق اهداف روسيا
الاستراتيجيه في اوكرانيا وان استغرق
الامر سنوات
هذا وقال الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسيين انه لا يستبعد سقوط مدينه بخمه
خلال ايام مشددا على ضروره ان لا يحدث ذلك
نقطه تحول في الحرب
[موسيقى]
روسيا تلقي بالمزيد من القوات وما تفتقده
من المهارات العسكريه تعوضه بكميات القوات
عانوا من خسائر كبيره ولكن في الوقت نفسه
لا يمكن استبعاد ان بخموت ستسقط في
النهايه خلال الايام المقبله لذا من المهم
ان لا ينعكس ذلك الى نقطه تحول في الحرب
وهو ايضا يؤكد ضروره عدم الاستهانه بروسيا
وفي ملف تفجير خط نورد ستريم للغاز في
سبتمبر الماضيه اكد الامين العام لحلفي
شمال الاطلسيا انا تحقيقات تجاريه ولم يتم
تحديده المسؤول الى الان
[موسيقى]
ما نفعله الان كان هناك هجوم على خط ستريم
عمل تخريبي لكن لم نتمكن من تحديد المسؤول
توجد التحقيقات محليه مستمره ومن الصواب
ان ننتظر نتائجها قبل ان نقول من وراء
التفجير ولكن هذا يظهر اهميه حمايه البنيه
التحتيه في البحار فتوجد الاف الكيلومترات
من انابيب الغاز والنفط وشبكات الكهرباء
وايضا كابلات الانترنت وهي بنيه تحتيه
ضروريه لمجتمعه
وتاتي تصريحات بعد ان نقل التقارير صحفيه
عن مصادر غربيه تاكيدها وجود معلومات
استخباراتيه غربيه عن وجود اياد اوكرانيه
وراء التفجير ووفقا لصحيفه تايمز
البريطانيه فان الناتو منع نشر هذه
المعلومات خشيه تتدهور العلاقات بين
اوكرانيا والمانيا واوضحت الصحيفه ان
الاستخبارات اطلقت على المتورط لقب الراعي
الخاص وهو اوكراني ثري يزعم اللا علاقه
بينه وبين الرئيس الاوكراني
الساده والعشرون من سبتمبر الماضي كانت
ساعه الصفر لتفجير خط نوت ستريم من قبل
جهه ما زالت مجهوله حتى اللحظه الاتهامات
يتم تبادلها بين عده دول بشان متسببه
بالتفجير والجديد خرج من المانيا مكتب
المدعي العام الفيدرالي اعلن ان قاربا
يشتبه في استخدامه في عمليه تخريب خطاي
انابيب الغاز تم تفتيشه في يناير الماضي
في اطار التحقيقات في المانيا وسائل اعلام
قالت ان الاعتقاد يدور حول استخدام القارب
لتنقل عبوات ناسفه عبر فريقه كماندس
اوكراني نقل المتفجرات انطلاقا من ميناء
روستوك الالماني منذ سبتمبر الماضي كان
احد السيناريوهات قيام غواصين بزرع
متفجرات في خطايا انابيب نورتريم واحد
واثنين وساد راي ايضا بان صعوبه الوصول
الى الانابيب على عمق سبعين مترا تحت
الماء تعني ان جهه لدوله ما وراء هذا
الهجوم تقارير استخباراتيه امريكيه
واوروبيه وجهت اصابع الاتهام الى جماعه
مؤيده لاوكرانيا لكن دون وجود دليل على
تورط القياده في الامر اتهام اوكرانيا
يعيد للاذهان هجمات سريه نوعيه ارتبطت
بكاف منها هجمات او محاولات هجوم
بمسيارات على قواعد عسكريه روسيه في
ديسمبر وفبراير الماضيين وعلى الحدث
الابرز كان تفجير جسر كورتش بشبه جزيره
القرم في اكتوبر الماضي والذي قيل ان
القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه هي التي نفذته
في جميع الاحداث التي ذكرناها امتنعت
اوكرانيا عن تبني المسؤوليه لكن قدرتها في
هذا الاطار لم تعد محل شك
وايضا سنتابع الان هذا الموضوع مع ضيفتنا
من كاف كيرا روجيك عضو البرلمان الاوكراني
وايضا في حزب جولوس اهلا بك سيده كيرا
بالنسبه لموضوع
ما هو الموقف الرسمي الاوكراني تجاه هذه
التقارير التي صدرت اليوم
شكرا جزيلا على استضافته في حقيقه الامر
نحن لم نطلع على هذه التقارير
ولكننا سمعنا ببعض التقارير التي وجهت
اصابع الاتهام الى اوكرانيا
بتلك التفجيرات التي طالت نور لكن حتى
اللحظه لم تقدم اي حقائق وكما ذكرتم في
صقرركم حتى الان لا يوجد ادله كافيه لكن
هناك نقطه مهمه اننا لسنا بجهه ارهابيه
وهناك فرق كبير بين اوكرانيا وروسيا فنحن
نتصرف بضمن احكامي وروح القانون بحثا عن
العداله لبلادنا ووفقا للقانون الدولي
ولهذا السبب فاننا نعمل على توثيق كافه
الجرائم روسيا ونحن نتصرف وفقا
للقواعد المنصوص عليها
كيف ترون ان جهه اوكرانيه هي وراء هذا
العمل وليست روسيا يعني هذه التقارير
تتحدث عن جهه اوكرانيه حتى ولو كما قيل
بان لا علاقه لها بالرئيس الاوكراني او
بالحكومه الاوكرانيه او باي جهه رسميه
اوكرانيه
كما تعلمون لابد لنا ان نشير انه على مر
السنوات التسعه الماضيه كانت روسيا قد هي
التي شرعت بالحرب ضدنا وقتلت الناس
الابرياء وروعت سكان المدنيين المسالمين
وترتكب كافه الجرائم الحروب هناك اناس
الان الذين باتوا
لم يعدوا يمتلكون منازل وقامت روسيا
بتفجير بيوتهم بالصواريخ
وبعد الهجمات الاخيره التي وقعت
قبل يومين اكثر من 60 شخصا قد لقوا حتمهم
وهناك اشخاص ايضا يتعرضون للاغتصاب بدون
سبب مبرر ولهذا السبب لا نعلم ما هي ما هي
الروايه التي يتم القصد منها في طرح قصه
التفجير لذا لابد لنا البحث عن المزيد من
الادله الدامغه قبل ان
نشير باصابع الاتجاه الى جهه ما لكن اقول
لكم بان مدى الخوف ومدى الضرر الذي تعرضت
له الذي تعرضت له بلادنا لا يمكن وصفه
من المستحيل من المستحيل ان يكون لنا طرفا
باي تنظيم تقوم او ترغبوا
بتغطيه هذه الحادثه سيدكره بحال تم التاكد
يبدو باننا سنتوقف ايضا مع هذه الصور من
جورجيا هناك اشتباكات بين قوات الامن وبين
متظاهرين في جورجيا طبعا بسبب هذا القانون
المثير للجدل حول الاعلام وبعض المنظمات
هذه التظاهرات ايضا
يبدو بانهم يحاولون اقتحام مقر البرلمان
هذه الصور نتابعها
ويبدو بان الشرطه ايضا تطالبهم باخلاء
المنطقه اذا هذه التظاهرات في جورجيا
متظاهرون يحاولون اقتحام البرلمان الشرطه
تطالبهم بان يبتعدوا وهذه التظاهرات
مستمره منذ ايام وهي بسبب
قانون او رفضهم لقانون
مثير الاثار الجدل حول الاعلام وبعض
المنظمات
وكانت رئيسه جورجيا تحدثت من الولايات
المتحده بخصوص هذا الامر وقالت بانها مع
هؤلاء
المحتجين بمطلبهم
وبانها لن تقبل بهذا القانون ولكن الان
نتابع عمليات واشتباكات ومحاولات اقتحام
الى البرلم ان الجورجي لمنع اقرار هذا
القانون هذه الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره
بين الشرطه والمحتجين
ساعود اليك سيده كيرا رودك العضو في
البرلمان الاوكراني وزعيمه حزب جولوس كنت
اريد ان اسال عن اذا تم تاكيد بان هناك
جهه اوكرانيه ما قامت بهذا التفجير يعني
لا يحرج اوكرانيا على يصعب موقف اوكرانيا
وخاصه مع الحلفاء مثل المانيا يعني وايضا
بان هناك جهات لا تعود الى الحكومه او
تتخطى الحكومه والرئيس الاوكراني وتقوم
بما تريد هي ان تفعله
نحن لم نرى البته اي دليل حول هذا الامر
لقد سمعنا فقط بوجود بعض التقارير قبل ان
ندلي باي تعليقات او تصريحات لابد لنا ان
ننظر الى هذه التقارير انا في الفتره
الحاليه لا استطيع ان اعلق واود ان
انظر الى محتواها لاننا في المرحله
الحاليه نركز
على ابقاء وحده الشعب قويه نعلم ان روسيا
تسعى
لاحداث حاله من الشقاق بها وتقوم بطرح
كافه الحملات الدعائيه والبروغاندا من اجل
من اجل الحديث عن ان الديمقراطيه الغربيه
تتقاتل فيما بينها لكن هذه الوحده اخذت
وقتا طويلا لتصبح قويه في مواجهه هذا
العدو وهذا ما تسعى روسيا لتخريبه
هذا الامر لا علاقه لروسيا فيه هذه
التقارير للولايات المتحده هذه تقارير
اوروبيه وهي حليفه لكم هي من تعطي هذا
السيناريو وهي ما تتحدث عن هذه الجهه على
كل حال اريد منك ان ان اسال ايضا عن الا
تخشون ان تتوتر علاقتكم مع حلفائكم وخاصه
مع الاوروبيين بحال ثبت ان هناك جهه
اوكرانيه قامت بذلك
قبل ان ادلي باي بيان لابد من النظر بهذه
التقارير لا اعتقده باننا اطلعنا هذه
التقارير
ولا نعلم مدى صحه هذه المزاعم التي طرحت
هذه التقارير لذا نرغب بالانتظار
نتمحص ما ورد فيها قبل الادلاء باي تعليق
شكرا لك من كيف عضو البرلمان الاوكراني
وزعمه حزب جولوس على المشاركه معنا في
العربيه 360
تلك كانت اولى الصور التي نشرت لما اعتقد
انه تسريب لاحد انابيب الغاز الروسي في
بحر البلطيق الشمالي في سبتمبر الماضي
سرعان ما تاكد الخبر والسرعان ما تبادل
الدول وعده جهات الاتهامات لاكبر عمليه
تخريب تهدد امن الطاقه في اوروبا مع
اشتعال الميدان في اوكرانيا خفت ضجيج
القصه لكن صوتا اخر كان اكثر حذرا ونشاطا
يبحث في خبايا ما حصل
لاشهر عمل سايمر هيرش الصحفي الاستقصائي
الامريكي الشهير على تقديم ادعاء مفصل
يورط الولايات المتحده والنرويج بانفجار
خط نورد ستريم الغازي تقرير هرش فجر قنبله
مفاجئه بوجه الادعاءات الامريكيه التي
اتهمت روسيا بالوقوف وراء العمليه بعد
استخدامها الخط كاداه للضغط على
الاوروبيين وتقديم تنازلات في الحرب
الاوكرانيه
تحقيق دفع الولايات المتحده لتبديل
روايتها حول المتهم وابراز متهم اخر
للتغطيه على تقرير هرش كما يرى مراقبونه
الصميد بالنسبه لي انها قصه غريبه بعض
الشيء لان هذه القصه ليس لها علاقه بنا
واعتقد ان التحقيق مع السلطات الرسميه
سيصف كل التفاصيل وسيكون بمثابه مجامله
لقواتنا الخاصه ولكن هذا ليس نشاطنا
اكتشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن تقييم
للاستخبارات الامريكيه يشير الى ان مجموعه
اوكرانيه نفذت الهجوم
لتتبعها روايه مطابقه ولكنها اكثر تفصيلا
لصحيفه الالمانيه التي كشفت عن تورط فريق
كوماندوس اوكراني بعمليه التفجير اما
روسيا فاسرت بدورها على فتح تحقيق مستقل
دون المماطله لا تزال اسئله وسيناريوهات
كثيره تدور حول الهجوم على نورد ستريم
وربما هناك من يفضل ابقاء الامر قيد
الكتمان لان الاجوبه قد تكون لها عواقب
تهدد بتجاوز الخطوط الحمر التي وضعتها
روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
خلال اجتماع مع الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو الى
تمديد اتفاقيات صفقه الحبوب ما بعد الثامن
عشر من مارس
[موسيقى]
اود التاكيد على اهميه تمديد اتفاق الحبوب
بعد الثامنه عشر من مارسا الحالي واهميه
العمل على تهيئه الظروف لاقصى استخدام
ممكن للبنيه التحتيه للتصدير عبر البحر
الاسود وفقا لاهداف المبادره
امر رئيس الاوكراني
مبادره حبوب البحر الاحمر ستستمر وان
اوكرانيا ارسلت اكثر من 140 الف طنا الى
اوروبا وكينيا
اتفقنا اليوم على ان استمرار مبادره حبوب
البحر الاسود بعد 18 من مارس امر ضروري
للغايه للعالم كله من المهم ايضا
الاستمرار في العمل من اجل مبادره الحبوب
من اوكرانيا الانسانيه كجزء من هذه
المبادره تمكنا بالفعل من جمع ما يقرب من
200 مليون دولار وارسال اكثر من 240 الف
طن من الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى اوروبا
وكينيا واثيوبيا والصومال والبلدان التي
تعاني من الجوع وانا متاكد من انه مع
الامم المتحده يمكننا تعزيز هذه المبادره
بشكل كبير مثل مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود
وهذا سيعطي المزيد من الضمانات للامن
الغذائي العالمي
كشف مصدر دبلوماسيون تركي انه لم تتم
تلبيته مطالب روسيا لتمديد اتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب التي تنتهي في الثامن عشر من الشهر
الجاري مؤكدا العمل على اقناع روسيا
بالتمديد وكانت موسكو ربطت موافقتها على
الاتفاقيه بشرط ان تكون عادله بين جميع
الاطراف
قال وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوشلو
خلال مؤتمرا صحفي مع نظيره الايراني في
انقره ان مسار استنه هو الاليه الوحيده
قيد التفعيل لحل الخلافات مع سوريا
تشترك
هو الاليه الوحيده لحال الخلافات مع سوريا
وابلغنا روسيا ان لا مشكله في مشاركه
ايران بالاجتماعات نخطط الان لعقد اجتماع
بين وزراء الخارجيه الاربعه روسيا عرضت
استضافه اجتماع تمهيدي تحضيرا للاجتماع
الرباعي وسنرسل ممثلنا في الخارجيه الى
موسكو الاسبوع المقبل كما ستحضر ايران
الاجتماع ايضا
قال مبعوث الامم المتحده الخاص لسوريا ان
المناخ الدولي اليوم قد يجعل الحل الشامل
في سوريا مستحيلا مشيرا الى ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا لها تاثير سلبي يعطل من مهمه
السلام
ان المناخ الدولي اليوم قد يجعل الحل
الشمل مستحيلا لا يزال يتعين علينا السعي
لتحقيق ذلك لنكن صريحين عندما ننظر الى
الحرب في اوكرانيا والتاثير الذي تحدثه
فانه لا يساعدنا في تسهيل ذلك لكن كما قلت
لا يمكن قبول الوضع الراهن نحن بحاجه الى
المضي قدما
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 سنتابع بعض لحظات في مصر
يقولون الحفيد اعز من الابن فماذا عن حفيد
الح
فيظ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اليوم العالمي للمراه
المراه الروسيه محاربه هنائها الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في الكرملين على
مجهوداتها خلال العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
الان بعد ان واجهت روسيا مره اخرى تهديدات
مباشره لامنها وسيادتها نرى العديد من
الامثله على الشجاعه والتصميم والاستعداد
للدفاع عن الحقيقه والدفاع عن الشعب
ومستقبل دولتنا وهو المستقبل الذين تمتعوا
به ونريده لانفسنا هناك نساء يؤدينا بشرف
واجباتهن العسكريه والخدميه والمهنيه
اما المراه في افغانستان فهي مهدوره
الحقوق تخرج بالعشرات للتظاهر امام مقر
بعثه الامم المتحده في كابول رغم القيود
التي تفرضها طالبان
[موسيقى]
اما في ايران في المراه الايرانيه في وضع
لا تحسد عليه عانت عاما من العنف مع باقي
الشعب ثم تلقت الضربه واحده تلو الاخرى
مره بمقتل مهساهميني ومره اخرى بحالات
التصميم المتعمده
انتفاضه بدات بصوت النسائي وكانت النساء
اولى ضحاياها مقتلوا مهسا اميني كان شراره
التظاهرات في ايران واستمرت الحركه
الشعبيه في البلاد لتكون المراه متصدره
المشهد
تزامنا مع يوم المراه العالمي وتلبيه
لدعوه الناشطات النسويات اتجهت نساء ايران
الى الشوارع منددات بممارسات النظام
القمعيه بحق المراه على وجه التحديد
رقم محاولات النساء في ايران تحصيل حقوقهن
بهدف الحريه لم يستطعنا حتى الان تحقيق
ذلك السبب يعود الى ممارسه النظام
الايراني وقوانينه التي تقمع النساء
لم تغب حوادث تسميم الطالبات في ايران عن
اللافتات بعد الجدل الذي اثرته تلك
الحوادث واختلاف الروايات حولها فمن جهه
المعرضه الايرانيه تتهم النظام بتلك
الممارسات وسط مطالبات دوليه بالتحقيق
فيها بينما يصر النظام الايراني على روايه
المؤامره وانخراط متظاهرين في تصميم
الطالبات
عمليات التسمم المستمره منذ ثلاثه اشهر لم
تترك اي مجال للشك في انها منظمه ويتم
تنفيذ هذه الجريمه حسب الاوامر خامنئي
ينتقم من فتيات ايران اللواتي لعبن دورا
حاسما في الانتفاضه الاخيره ويريد ترهيبهن
قمع وقتل وتعذيب وتسميم ممارسات ليست
غريبه عن النظام الايراني بحق شعبه عامه
والنساء خاصه اسماء كثيره كانت ضحيه
ونداءات دوليه تطالب النظام بوقف العنف
ومحاسبته على تلك الانتهاكات الى عمر
العربيه
من الرياض تنضم الي امال مدلله السفيره
السابقه لدى الامم المتحده سيده امال اهلا
بك معنا الى اي مدى اصبح موضوع المراه
وهدر حقوقها اصبح بالشراكه بين عادات
وتقاليد وبين ايضا انظمه سياسيه لا تريد
التغيير ولا تريد ان ترى ان المراه لديها
هذه الحقوق
كل عام وانت بخير اولا
وشكرا على الفرصه
الواقع انك على حق ان هذه الشراكه بين
هذين العاملين جعل وضع المراه في وضع في
وضع مزري هذه الايام وخصوصا ان التقدم
الذي تم تحقيقه في سنوات الماضيه يتاكل
الان ونجد ان المراه او وضع المراه يتراجع
عن السنوات السابقه العنف ضد المراه يزداد
الظلم ضد المراه حقوق المراه يجري التخلي
عنها في الكثير من البلدان لاسباب سياسيه
لاسباب اجتماعيه
باسباب الحروب
لا يمكن ان ننسى ان جائحه كوفيد ادت الى
الحرمان المراه من الكثير من حقوقها
فالمراه الان في وضع صعب جدا بسبب هذا
التراجم حقوقها ولكن هناك استثناءات وانا
سعيده انني في الرياض لانني وجدت ان في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه المملكه
الاستثناء اليوم عن الذي يحدث حول العالم
بالنسبه لموضوع المراه بالتحول التاريخي
الذي يجري في المملكه اعطى المراه فرصه
ذهبيه ونرى انه في الوقت الذي يتم التراجع
في حول العالم المراه السعوديه تتقدم
بسرعه الضوء
المستقبل وهذا امر جيد جدا وكانت كنت
سعيده جدا ان اراه خلال مؤتمر حضرته وكان
الوجود المراه السعوديه وجود فعال ووجود
مميز فهناك
فهناك وضع صعب ولكن هناك استثناءات ومبروك
للسعوديه في هذا الامر دكتور مدللي بموضوع
مثلا ايران الخطوره ايضا بانه ايضا تصبح
المراه وموضوع حقوقها يصبح ماده ووسيله
لتغطيه على امور اخرى لها ايضا جوانب
سياسيه يعني مثلا نعطي نموذج ايران قتلت
مهسه امينه الان
خرجت الاحتجاجات لحتى نلهي الناس عن هذه
الاحتجاجات هناك الان تسميم لبعض الطالبات
في المدارس
خطوره هذا الامر يعني ايضا المراه اصبحت
وكانها فتيل يشعل من قبل هذه الانظمه حتى
تحقق اهدافها
انت تعرفين تعلمين ان الانظمه القمعيه
تقوم به اي شيء
تستطيع ان تقوم به للحفاظ على وجودها في
السلطه والوضع في ايران ليس بعيدا عن هذا
الامر لان الذي موجود في ايران اليوم هو
مطالب سياسيه ومطالب حقوق انسانيه للمراه
اجتماع هذين العاملين في وجه نظام لا يريد
التغيير يؤدي الى الكثير من القمع ويؤدي
الى هذا الوضع الذي تجد في نفسها المراه
الايرانيه فيه فاذا هذا جزء من المعركه
السياسيه ولكن كما قلت المركز السياسيه
هذه تتداخل فيها الكثير من العوامل خصوصا
العوامل الاجتماعيه ومن المراه وعوامل
تاريخيه
المؤسف ان للمراه الايرانيه تواجه كل هذه
العوامل في نفس الوقت وتواجه نظام صعب
يستخدم العنف مع الاسف لحتى الان لم
تستطيع ان تحقق اي نتائج فعاله ولا تزال
ضحيه في هذا الامر وهنا ايضا لا يجب ان
ننسى نساء اخرى حول العالم التي هي ايضا
كما ذكرت في تقريركم في ايران في
افغانستان الماساه الكبرى في افغانستان
حيث المراه تحرم من حق التعلم من حق
المشاركه في المجتمع من حق الذهاب الى
طبيب حتى هذا التراجع
وسبابه الوضع السياسي المتدهور في العالم
وهذا هذا التقدم للانظمه القمعيه حول
العالم طب دكتور مدلل الان نريد حلول يعني
ما هو دور المراه من اجل ان تحصل على هذه
الحقوق وايضا دور المنظمات في دعمها
لحصولها على هذه الحقوق وخاصه يعني نحن
وصلنا الى نحن في عام 20 22 يعني ليس من
المقبول ان نرى مراه 23 ايضا
غير مقبول ان نرى مراه تقمع في الطريق من
اجل
ملابسها او تمنع من ذهبها الى المدرسه او
الى الجامعه
مع الاسف اننا نعيش في سنه 2023
وفي القرن 21 والذي كان متامل ان تكون
المراه في هذا الوقت قد حققت الكثير من
النجاحات ووصلت الى مرحله متقدمه من
الحصول على حقوقها ولكن كما راينا في بعض
الكتابات او خطابات التي سمعناها في الامم
المتحده اليومين الاخرين انه نحتاج الى
300 سنه لكي تتم المساواه بين المراه
والرجل لان المساواه حتى الان لم يتم يتم
ردم هذه الفجوه في الحقوق والواجبات وفي
الاجور وفي كل شيء ومع الاسف ايضا ان
العنف ضد المراه يزداد اكثر واكثر في حول
العالم فكل عشر دقائق هناك امراه تقتل من
قبل احد اقاربها او احد عائلتنا مع الاسف
ان المراه هي الحلقه الضعيفه بهذه بهذه
المعركه تجاه الاستبداد واتجاه الظلم
واعتقد ان المعركه ستكون طويله وبطبيعه
الامد لان الوضع السياسي في العالم وضع
يتجه نحو الاسوء ولا يتجه نحو الايجابيه
والحلول الامور تتعقد دوليا وكل ما تتعقد
المراه كما نرى في الحروب المراه هي
الاولى التي تدفع ثمن الحرب وهي الاولى
التي يتم استبعادها عندما يتم البحث في
الحلول وفي المفاوضات السلميه فلا نجدها
على طاوله مفاوضات ولا دور سياسي لها فهي
ايضا الضحيه ولكن لا يصبح لها ان تكون
فاعله في ايجاد الحلول وهذا المطلوب اليوم
المطلوب مخصصه من المنظمات الدوليه وما
الهيئات الدوليه التي تاتي اليها لديها
نفود ان يكون للمراه وجود فاعل في حل
النزاعات لانه اثبت
الابحاث انه عند عندما توجد المراه في
طاوله المفاوضات وفي مفاوضات معينه تكون
النتيجه مستمره لها استمراريه اكثر وجود
المراه يؤدي الى نجاح العمليه وتجد حلول
في بعض الاوقات اسرع وتنجح في بعض الاوقات
اكثر من الرجل شكرا لك يعني لا يمل من
الحديث عن المراه وحقوقها ووصولها الى
القمم لانها بالنهايه هي التي تبني الاسره
والاسره هي المجتمع وهي ايضا قادره ولديها
كل الامكانيات لقياده العالم حتى شكرا لك
دكتوره امل المدللي السفيره السابقه لدى
الامم المتحده على المشاركه معنا في
العربيه 360
في ملف اخر مرتبط بايران تعهدت فرنسا
والمانيا وبريطانيا في بيان بمحاسبه طهران
اذا لم تلتزم بتعهدتها لوكاله الطاقه
الدوليه وقالت الدول الثلاث انها لم تقتنع
بتفسيرات ايران عن اليورانيوم المخصب
بالنسبه 84% والا تبرير مدني لهذه الخطوات
واعتبر ثلاثيه الاوروبيه انا تخصيب
الايراني بنسب متقدمه يعد تصعيدا خطيرا
جدا
النقاشات داخل قاعه مجلس المحافظين هنا
حول ايران ضغط عليها المخاوف من اثار
اليورانيوم العاليه التخصيب التي عثر
عليها مفتشون تابعون للوكاله في منشاه
فوردو الايرانيه والتي بلغت تقريبا 84
بالمئه ولكن الدبلوماسيين الغربيين هنا
يقولون انهم يتمهلون بالتصعيد لاعطاء
ايران فرصه لشرح اسباب العثور على اثار
اليورانيوم العالي التخصيب هذا
الدبلوماسيون او الدول الاوروبيه حذرت حتى
ايران من ان عدم اعطاء جواب لامينه عام
الوكاله الدوليه رافاييل جروستي كما وعدت
وبشكل سريع سيعرضها للمحاسبه وقالت بان
الرد الذي اعطته حتى الان غير مقنعه
اسابيع قليله ستظهر ما اذا كانت ايران
ستفي بتعهداتها التي اطلقتها على رافايا
الجروسسي امين عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه هنا ام انها تماطل من جديد وهكذا
مماطله ستدفع بالدول الغربيه للدعوه
الاجتماع طارق لمجلس المحافظين كما اكد
لنا دبلوماسيون حتى قبل اجتماع المجلس
الدوري في يونيو المقبل وطرح مشروع قرار
جديد يدين ايران يكون الثالث خلال عام
واحد راغده العربيه فيينا
فيديو اليوم من مصر الفن عند اغلب اهله
موهبه والممارسه لكن في قريه بالحرانيه في
الجيزه وفطره في هذا المركز المتخصص لا
تحتاج العاملات لاكثر من جوله وسط الطبيعه
نسخ مشهدا في الذاكره ثم العوده الى العمل
لنسجه على لوح خشبي بسيط اما النتيجه
فلوحات فنيه يدويه فريده تاخذ الكثير من
الوقت اشهر وربما عام لكن ميزتها ان ايا
منها لا تشبه الاخرى لان اصلها في عقل من
نسجتها ولذا حين تباع تباع بسعر يعكس ذلك
اما صوره اليوم في العربيه من كانتاكي
الامريكيه صوره مميزه للقاء عائلي بين
جيلين مختلفين بالطبع هي ليست ام وابنتها
الفارق واضح اما الحقيقه فهي ام وابنه
ابنه ابنه ابنتها سته اجيال بين ميدل
البالغه من العمر 98 عاما وزافيا البالغه
من العمر سبعه اسابيع السؤال هو ما الذي
يمكن للجده ان تحكيه من ذكريات وتستوعبه
حفيده الحفيده
الى هنا تنتهي ملفات واخبار العربيه 360
ولكن اخبار العربيه دائما تستمر والان مع
اخبار الساعه والزميل صهيب ماذا لديك صهيب
تفضل مساء الخير المزيد طبعا في جولتنا
السريعه الشامله والمتنوعه اخبار الساعه
بعد قليل في الصداره معركه باخموت تبقى في
اولى العناوين طبعا مع حديث النيت عن
احتماليه ان تسقط المدينه بيدروس خلال
ايام هناك
سنتابعك شكرا لك
[موسيقى]